welcome back to the show that today
features a hulking hunk hoot nanny
battling it out for superhero supremacy
are two fellows who can
flex to save the world or fight to win
your heart because ryan reynolds
is taking on hugh jackman and although
they weren't asked to be physically in
studio the host doesn't allow abs on
this program
we have a feeling this decade-long
frenemy bromance will finally be
resolved
in one corner it's that guy from the
pizza place no no
the other guy not the girl the guy ryan
reynolds is his name
and he's taken on the land down under
his finest export
since paul hogan mr hugh jackman
i forgot about the hens horse oh they're
going to have me on the ship list
but i didn't see thor in that last movie
and i think i can outrun thor at this
point
why does this donut look all right you
look like melted ice cream
oh we're still rolling here's how we'll
determine a winner round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score
round three iconic rolls round four
the feud and then i'll toss in a wild
card round that could involve
x-men origins wolverine i really hope it
doesn't but if i get desperate
that's how you're gonna know it's
people's sexiest man 2008 versus
people's sexiest man 2010
the winner takes on blake shelton the
loser
has to keep their shirt on in the next
movie even the sleeves boys
let's get it on i'm about to do to you
what limp bizkit get into music in the
late 90s
my god you ever shut up pal no not when
i'm awake
round one box office the fact that we're
blessed with this battle today
is a testament to the power of the
silver screen and these two foes took
very different paths to enjoying their
current a-list status
ryan reynolds graduated from the world
of sitcoms to the big screen
around the same time we were all
panicking about y2k
and it was y2k a big mutant party that
unleashed the accomplished
theater performer hugh jackman unto the
world of cinema
in the original x-men film hey hey
it's me prove it you're a dick
so let's start with one of the longest
running and most successful comic book
franchises
ever and its marquee character what kind
of monster
are you the wolverine
a relative unknown when the movie was
released hugh jackman wasted no time in
making himself
one with the adamantium claws and he's
gone on to play the character in a
starring role a total of seven
times and that's how many super bowls
tom brady has with a couple of fun
cameos
in between it's always nice when a movie
lets you get the one pg-13 f-bomb with
your only line
go [ __ ] yourself all told hughes x-men
films represent his
top four money makers at the worldwide
box office headlined by x-men
days of future past at 837 million
dollars
seven of jackman's top 10 worldwide hits
are those x-men films
with the remaining outliers being happy
feet les miserables
and the greatest showman don't worry
most people forgot to include happy feet
but you never underestimate a penguin
movie
you don't have to be beautiful
[Music]
hugh jackman's worldwide box office
totals a robust eight and a half
billion dollars making for a per film
average of 242 million
quite the tall mountain for ryan
reynolds to climb but let's not forget
he also exists in the x-men universe as
the character he was seemingly born to
play
deadpool okay guys let's get out there
and make a difference
those two stand-alone deadpool flicks
are ryan's best output in terms of
worldwide box office grocers
and yeah i mean gross literally those
movies are for a reason besides
nobody's getting hurt
as they combine for 1.6 billion bucks in
receipts
like jackman reynolds also has a big
animated property in his quiver
the croods which did 642 million dollars
across the globe
i got it can we have the penguins battle
the cave people
who's better at monogamy i wonder far be
it from us to pigeonhole ryan with one
big franchise he's also a fun little
part of hobbs and shaw
and stars and detective pikachu green
lantern
okay i said it it's in his top ten it
made a ton of money hey
i might have liked it just fine when i
saw it i haven't revisited it since
i just can we let's just move on cool
huh
to the world of romantic comedies both
gentlemen have made quite a career
in just this genre alone but ryan
reynolds has the most buck earning
bragging rights here
as the proposal is the only rom-com to
grace either fella's top ten
it clocks in at number seven on his list
with 393
worldwide millions i gotta think a huge
chunk of that is in canadian dollars
thank you sandra love you
so reynolds puts up a good fight as his
total worldwide gross over 37 movies
is 6.53 billion making for a sterling
218 million dollar average per outing
and thus i'm torn between ryan reynolds
who might have a little more
diversity of movie role going for him
against hugh jackman
who has the stats largely thanks to that
one gigantic franchise
and under normal circumstances i might
award round one to ryan reynolds but the
most gigantic reason that
x-men movies are so gigantic sarcastic
is wolverine look we like cyclops storms
are badass professor x's smart things
but if we don't buy the guy playing
logan
i don't know that we're going back to x2
or suffering through the last stand
hugh is wolverine and wolfie is x-men
regardless of what else you call him
weapon x wins the round the cool side
pompadour gets the point
while deadpool still remains silent
finally figured out how to shut you up
round two
tomato meter slash audience store okay
so your big summertime popcorn flicks
have been released we all waited around
the block to see them opening weekend
but what did we think walking out of an
x-men or a deadpool
furthermore were we satisfied with the
smaller gems we had to drive to that one
cool theater on the edge of town to see
like buried or butter let's let the
critics have their say first as we delve
into that muddiest of scoreboards the
tomato meter
they're both rotten the whole lot of
them well at least the overall average
for a jackman or reynolds picture is
rotten but just barely as hugh jackman's
flicks
average 57 percent and ryan reynolds
earns an average of 54
per film i really want these guys to be
watching this vid together is that just
like ribbing each other good naturally a
little bit
but not so loud that they step over my
jokes
hey guys big fan
my close personal friend hugh jackman
does lean on his wolverine claws to
climb to fresh town
as four of his x-men films appear in his
tomato meter top 10
including the best score for either
fella logan
at 93 percent
but he also shows his range as the
animated delight the missing link is at
89 percent
eddie the eagles at 82 percent and
prisoners clocks in at 81
you see the other prisoners yikes i
won't even let anyone else watch my dog
after seeing that
okay so ryan reynolds has another uphill
fight on his mids but the dude's in
great shape
and he got me a deal on mint mobile do
you have a cell phone
91 is his best effort on the tomato
meter thanks to mississippi grind
is that a that's not a deadpool no it's
just a movie it's a really good movie
ben mendelsohn adventureland buried and
definitely maybe also pop in his tomato
meter top ten
as do those wacky deadpool twins
measuring quite fresh at 85 percent for
part one
84 for part d it's too close to call
here so let's hop on over to the
audience score god damn it i'm gonna do
this the old-fashioned way
it's a tight ball game here as well
except both dudes have a fresh film
average
jackman leads again with 67 to reynolds
is 62.6 percent
and remember how they had a rotten
average on the tomato meter so i made
them feel better by regaling you all
with their freshest hits
well the audience score average is fresh
so let's get rotten and see who had the
worst stinkers
i smell funny let's get right to the
high
low lights ryan reynolds green lantern
is at 45
okay that's not terrible how about x-men
origins wolverine which stars hugh
jackman but features ryan reynolds
omg it's it 58
it's not even in his top 10 worst movies
what
is oh i know what his worst one is movie
43
yeah it's a straight trash 4 on the
tomato meter but it does fare better
with an audience score of 24
and i guarantee you all 24 of those
percentage points
are thanks to hugh specifically his chin
watch the movie it happens right away
then you can turn it off forever
other notable low bar setters in
jackman's worst 10 include deception at
31 percent
the front runner at 39 and pan at 40
percent
meanwhile ryan reynolds has to reconcile
with ripd
i got it which somehow made it all the
way up to 38 percent
the in-laws at 40 and his record low
the alarmist at 15 percent are we sure
he wasn't also in movie 43 there's a lot
of famous people saying yes to that
boggles the mind if you want all the
movies these two
towering titans have made and combine
their top tens you'd find them virtually
tied at the top of the tomato meter
as each would have five films
represented but the worst of the tomato
meter
leans towards ryan reynolds who has six
of the lowest 11 films on that scale
okay we're [ __ ] and even though one of
them is national lampoon's van wilder
which features national lampoon's animal
house as tim matheson
as national lampoon's van wilder's
father the numbers don't lie
we expected a close matchup but at the
end of two rounds it's ryan reynolds
zero
captain bald chin two i fully expect
that to be edited out but
i had to take the shot but remember
don't forget to help yourselves to lots
and lots of jelly old fun
round three iconic characters and the
hits keep on coming for ryan reynolds
you're down 0-2
and now you got to defeat the guy that
plays wolverine in an iconic character
matchup
that's like trying to be clint eastwood
in a the sun's in my eyes but i'm still
a tough cowboy contest
can it be done there's only one way to
find out and that's for me
to keep reading the stuff that i already
wrote myself but i've forgotten
really hugh jackman is wolverine
wolverine
is hugh jackman the box office billions
and worldwide adulation aside
wolverine is the entire linchpin of the
x-men universe's popularity
sure he can be cast as an unwitting
sidekick in a few of the movies
and rarely does a love triangle work out
in his favor
but still wolverine is just about as
iconic a role as we've seen in this
millennium
you picked the wrong let's pile on top
of that with some other hugh jackman
accomplishments over the years
like jean valjean the guy you first read
about in kliff's notes as a freshman in
high school
was brought to life on the big screen
courtesy of song and dance man hugh
and he delivered a stirring performance
that resonates so well
we didn't even have to talk about
russell crowe singing in that flick
right
right you have brought the gift of life
that earned jackman his lone oscar
nomination way back in 2013
and you gotta think with his talent
there's more on the way
in fact audiences thought he might even
be able to seal a win as they flocked
time and time again to see
the greatest showman he plays a
character loosely based on pt barnum and
belts out number after number of catchy
show tuned greatness
no oscar glory was in his future for
that but he did earn his third golden
globe nomination
which is more than anything anyone can
say for pan so
we move on to ryan reynolds
he's had a few minutes for an all-time
great inspirational speech to get
himself back in the ball game
or at least a better pep talk than eddie
the eagle got from hugh jackman
thanks i think okay enough about hugh
ryan reynolds is deadpool
and i mean that in the spiritual sense
as well certain folks were put on this
planet to do
certain things the wright brothers were
made to fly above earth neil armstrong
was here to leave earth entirely
and stanley kubrick was here to film the
moon landing in some folks's conspiracy
theories
about neil armstrong but when you see
deadpool and particularly with a set of
eyes that has witnessed ryan reynolds
his rise to stardom
like these baby browns have you see the
culmination of all that
charm wit affinity for romance and yes
superhero worthy abs wolverine is the
more iconic character as of right now
but hugh jackman's time is logan has
come and gone deadpool
is now ready to seize that spotlight
adding on to wade wilson
that's deadpool not the 80s minnesota
vikings quarterback is another iconic
character played by reynolds
chris brander if that name doesn't ring
a bell the face
certainly will oh my god
ryan artificially plumped for the
flashback scenes in just
friends the rom-com that doubles as a
christmas movie that triples
as one of the best comedic romances
since the turn of the century
stupid stupid stupid
yes hugh jackman has had some nice rc
moments
but reynolds's memorable turn opposite
and amazing anna ferris
scores him major points okay she's got a
bit of a headache
it's not that bad
[Music]
as does his even more successful turn
and the proposal
and has a dad telling a very timely love
story to his daughter
indefinitely maybe that's a rom-com
resume tom hanks wouldn't mind having
even when he was busy making us quickly
want to forget that wolverine origins
was a thing ryan reynolds was arguably
the best part of that entire flick
manicure no no no the rewind to the
beginning the parts where they let him
talk
see it's quality stuff okay
people are dead ryan reynolds also
elevated the material and gave some
panache to lesser movies like blade
trinity
selfless and the high octane netflix
film six underground
put that in your dvdq today you want to
get out and compare or should we maybe
think about going hugh jackman's career
resume during awards season indicates he
has more wins and nominations than his
bitterly friendly rival and wolverine is
the most iconic character you're going
to hear about today
or on most episodes of this year program
but ryan reynolds filmography boasts an
impressive variety of characters you
know
love and even want to revisit even if
some of the movies themselves were
destined for the
rotten side of the tomato meter home
runs are great but in this round it's
reynolds who moneyballs his way to a win
and he's finally on the scoreboard
it's two to one and neither of our
competitors were in moneyball
so we smoothly transition into the next
round which means the fat lady
should be singing right about
now
[Music]
round four the feud
i truly madly definitely no maybes about
it
love this feud that fell apart quickly
in an era where we have no idea how to
relate to the real human beings behind
the star facade
it's a nice side dish to watch ryan
reynolds and hugh jackman constantly
fire zingers at each other via social
media
famous third parties or on late night
talk shows hugh jackman
has eyebrow implants but how did this
epic contest of jokey one-upsmanship
begin in the first place
it started with how all good natured
rivalries gestate
scarlett johansson yep it's true at
least according to hugh jackman
the headlining star of x-men origins
wolverine
we i gotta talk about this movie why
x-men origins reunite yeah
oh that's because when hugh and ryan met
for the first time it was
on that set jackman and scarlett had
already been good pal since working
together on the prestige and ryan had
just married
scarlet thus hugh kept teasing him on
set
reminding the newlywed to be on his best
behavior it's been love ever since
even if it didn't always feel like that
um you did see it right man
oh no i did yeah yeah i mean that's yeah
things heated up once ryan claimed the
crown once held by hugh
that being the coveted title of people's
sexiest man alive in 2010.
jackman had been that dude in 2008 but
as recently as 2019
when john legend was ushered into the
legendary fraternity
jackman used the occasion as an
opportunity to roast reynolds
reminding legend on instagram to not be
that one percent of celebs that people
missed on
and that's just one example of the
social media links these two fellas will
go
another highlight was ryan reynolds
captioning a pic of jackman with adoring
fans as
i'm pretty sure those are protesters the
eternal good guy jackman taking veiled
shots at ryan
the smarmy wit of reynolds bullying hugh
it's nearly impossible to declare a
winner in this round because they're so
good at battling the other that it's a
batman and joker situation
you can't eliminate one because as a
famous joker once said
you complete me do you ever age
not since 2008. you know gorgeous but it
was ryan reynolds who may have gotten
the biggest
if not last laugh when he used his own
starring vehicle deadpool 2
to canonize this frenemy rivalry into
comic book
film war wade has taken multiple shots
at jackman throughout the two films and
we fans are holding our breath
that we get another cameo of wolverine
having some sort of revenge in
deadpool's next
outing while we await that outcome i
give major points to jackman for getting
jake gyllenhaal involved in the
shenanigans
and please never stop posting the dorky
throwback pics but between the deadpool
stuff
the birthday wedding anniversary barbs
and the flat-out creativity of ryan
reynolds always nailing the perfect
troll timing
i have to give the slightest of edges to
hal jordan here
yes hugh i referred to him as his green
lantern character that was for you
hey let's see ryan reynolds do that
like a great offensive shootout in the
nfl this game will probably come down to
whoever has the ball last
and no not the ones on your chin they
don't count reynolds has come all the
way back to tie the game
and just in time for our final round
[ __ ]
wolverine what a dick
the wild card round range
here's the thing about likable people
whether it's hugh jackman
ryan reynolds me sure we can make you
like a version of us
even if it's a fictional character that
exudes our unique real life traits
but to be a truly great actor you need
to have that rarest of abilities that
allows you to transcend looks and
personality
and displaces you into another being
entirely
so much so that even the audience barely
remembers the real you
can you disappear into a wide variety of
roles that will suit different tastes
and sensibilities
in short do you have range that's what
we need from hugh and ryan in this wild
card round
whoever proves themselves more worthy
will in fact be crowned the winner
of today's show full disclosure i so
badly wanted to make this whole round
just a fight between
origins x-men wolverine whatever the
hell that movie's called
and green lantern but alas this is
technically a celebration of high art so
i'll stick to the movies that don't sew
ryan's mouth shut
and the films that don't give wolverine
claws that look like they're straight
out of who framed roger rabbit
both leading men are contenders in this
round simply because they've been
successful
in virtually every section that
blockbuster video offers
action films are a given x-men deadpool
swordfish safe house and the list goes
on and on
and while ryan reynolds might have the
edge when it comes to romantic comedies
hugh jackman certainly has the edge in
sweeping musical extravaganzas
popular films like the greatest showman
critical darlings like les miserables
or other movies like australia prove
jackman is a true performer who can hit
all the notes dance all the moves and
even sell out arenas doing those show
tunes live across the globe
and even though i enjoyed him and ashley
judd and someone like you just fine
it's hard to not be impressed with how
effortlessly ryan reynolds can put
down the deadpool weaponry and insulting
wit to show us a more gentle sense of
humor in lasting rom-coms like the
proposal
definitely maybe just friends hell he's
even known perfect and the less
memorable ones like the change up
waiting and buying the cow and so what a
few jackman can glide all over the stage
while carrying a tune
ryan reynolds can evoke a wide net of
emotion even if he literally can't move
at all
did y'all see buried is that a party
flick but it's worth checking out
the guys in a coffin the whole time
like that's like the entire plot i'm
buried in a box
did either of these folks ever attempt
to roll outside their wheelhouse and
fail to pull it off
both dipped their toes in the horror
genre with not the best of results
reynolds had a beard that would make old
man logan take notice in the remake of
the amityville har
but it wasn't all that creepy unless
you're pretending the guy from two guys
and a girl lost the pizza place and then
his sanity that's a little fun
hugh played the legendary van helsing in
the accurately titled
van helsing but weak effects in a subpar
storyline put way too much even upon his
broad shoulders
so if we tally it all up it's anyone's
ball game as to who has more true range
i'll even allow the weight room ability
into this fray who can bench press more
hugh who can squat more still hugh who
eats more grilled chicken breasts on set
definitely hugh but ryan reynolds is
funny man
and being as naturally funny as we are i
mean he is
gets you far in life so far you might
even get rick moranis to hang out in
your cell phone company ad
that was awesome what do you want me to
do you want me to say something about
min uh no that would have been smart
real talk i'm inching towards ryan
reynolds here as a comedian i can tell
you when you're on your funny game
you are always the life of the party
people want to hear your humorous yarns
you can talk your way into multiple free
beverages
and everyone wants to be your best
friend
unless someone shows up to that party
who can sing
and dance and you can do both of those
things
really really well i was up here
god damn it plus he's funny to boot look
if you can sell out broadway bust out
the claws on the silver screen and keep
up with ryan reynolds in a never-ending
game of one-upsmanship
you got uncanny range and that is why
the x-person i'm selecting to win this
round
and thus the match is hugh jackman
congrats logan
you did it i'm gonna take everything
back if you don't cameo in every
deadpool movie here two four
every one cause you can do it like you
do or you can do like me
stay in the cage or you finally take the
keys
so there you have it kitties it was an
epic brawl between two of the mightiest
cinematic heavyweights of modern times
and the best news is they're both still
going strong did you see your winner
hugh jackman in bad education
it's a great little piece of
entertainment on the home box office
and your runner up ryan reynolds he'll
be just fine with more big time comic
book movie zaniness on the way
and what about that rumored clue remake
you'll meet no better fan of the 1985
classic than i but if anyone can match
that beloved original
i'm betting it's ryan reynolds in the
study
with the candlestick god i hope the
movie is better than what i just said
[Applause]
thanks for tuning in today gang reminder
you can check out the entire versus
catalog
starring me i make you nervous hugh
that was a bouncy c
[Laughter]
right here on the rotten tomatoes
channel or on youtube and remember
today's results are just my opinion so
feel free to hit me up on social media
and chime in with your take
do you love wolverine or deadpool more
who's currently winning the ryan hugh
bromance feud
and if it ever happens who should ryan
reynolds cast hugh jackman as in
clue until next time this is mark ellis
saying i'm gonna go home and
sleep with my wife